bonsoir et soyez les bienvenus dans
cette édition blatter qui sera réalisée
en grande partie depuis cannes pour le
53e festival international du film alors
nous évoquerons les films en compétition
notamment le choc d'hier avec la
chanteuse islandaise bjork et catherine
deneuve qui sera notre invité privilégié
pendant de longues minutes au cours de
cette édition mais nous évoquerons si ce
qui se passe sous ce palais du festival
c'est à dire le marché du film 1
milliards de dollars d'échangés de vente
c'est l'une des enquêtes de cette
édition spéciale en direct de cannes
après l'actualité après vous donc
béatrice mon sort claude bonsoir à tous
dans l'actualité de ce jeudi le titre
que nous allons développer dans la
première partie de cette édition
gilbert trigano et son fils jugées dans
la sphère du crash de cap skirring au
sénégal en 92 ou 30 clients du club med
avait trouvé la mort les trigano nie
toute responsabilité coup de théâtre au
rpr edouard balladur considérant que les
jeux sont déjà faits se retire de la
course à la candidature
évoquant le manque de transparence
nombreuses réactions politiques
journée de grève dans les lycées
collèges des 90 saignant des assistantes
sociales aux cuisiniers en passant par
le personnel d'entretien un mouvement de
ceux qui se disent oubliés
et puis le rapport sur la pollution
un rapport inquiétant les eaux troubles
dans 11 départements et 30 communes de
france
figure emblématique du club méditerranée
gilbert trigano et son fils
comparaissent en correctionnelle depuis
cet après midi pour déterminer leur
responsabilité dans l'accident d'avion
du cap skirring qui avait fait en 92 je
vous le disais 30 morts et 26 blessés
y at il eu coupable négligence de la
part des dirigeants du club med qui
n'auraient pas assurer des conditions de
vol satisfaisante à leurs clients
gilbert trigano répond en évoquant une
erreur humaine du pilote dominique
verdeilhan à la voirie
à 80 ans gilbert trigano a une fierté
avoir contribué à faire voyager plus de
35 millions de touristes leur avoir fait
découvrir des endroits insolites dans le
monde entier alors la catastrophe du
casque ring en février 92 n'a pour lui
qu'une seule explication la fatalité
daniel solvay n'a pas la même approche
il était dans l'avion il est un des 26
rescapés huit jours de coma deux ans
d'hospitalisation et de rééducation
quand il a vu l'état de l'avion il a
hésité à monter à bord
alors j'ai vu cet avion j'ai eu peur
j'ai demandé si on pouvait si je pouvais
me rendre au cap skirring par un autre
moyen on m'a dit non
et à ce moment là je monte dans l'avion
avec ma compagne a en mettant l'arrière
devant une sortie de secours
une place à l'arrière du converser v 640
d'une compagnie gambienne qui lui a sans
doute sauvé la vie un vol de nuit une
procédure d'approché surtout une méprise
l'avion temps de se poser non sur un
aéroport mais sur une voie d'accès un
grand hôtel pour gilbert trigano la
catastrophe est uniquement dû à une
erreur de pilotage
une erreur humaine mais y est mort
pauvre en mémoire alors venir qui nous
qui nous sommes pour rien ça serait
compensé un drame par une injustice et à
l'audience on frissonne en entendant le
constat de la commission denquête
dégradation visible de la carlingue
aucune maintenance régulière seize
éléments défectueux recensé absence d'un
radar d'altitude assurance de l'avion
n'ont payé un mécanicien sans formation
des problèmes de vue et d'audition
pour le pilote sans oublier les
incompatibilités d'humeur entre le
pilote et son copilote nous n'avons
jamais été saisi de problèmes de
sécurité dit gilbert trigano les seuls
griefs qui nous étaient faits
concernaient les retards sur la ligne
toujours au chapitre judiciaire devant
la cour de cassation l'éventuelle
révision de la condamnation de patrick
dils condamné lien onze ans pour le
meurtre de deux enfants cette requête en
révision amènerait à considérer que le
tueur en série francis heaulme présent à
l'époque des faits sur les lieux du
crime pourraient en être l'auteur
valérie ermite christian galley pour les
familles des victimes
c'est une large blessure qui s'ouvre à
nouveau
pour les parents de patrick dils c'est
en revanche le dernier espoir de voir
peut-être un jour leur fils innocente
est très important de votre vie puisque
de l'avis de patrick en 1986 alexandre
et cyril et 8 ans ont retrouvé mort
frappé très violemment à coups de
pierres le long d'une voie ferrée
sept mois plus tard patrick dils alors
âgé de 16 ans passent aux aveux des
aveux très précis très détaillé le jeune
il se rétractera par la suite pour
clamer son innocence mais sera condamnée
à la perpétuité en 1989
ce n'est que huit ans plus tard que l'on
apprendra que francis heaulme
aujourd'hui célèbre tueur en série a
croisé les enfants à l'heure du crime
même s'il nie les avoir tués un élément
nouveau très important pour l'avocate
générale mais qui ne suffit pas à
disculper patrick dils en revanche elle
demande un supplément d'information et
une analyse adn sur les pierres qui ont
servi à tuer le parfait puisque le tube
à gaza ne pourra aboutir à ce que l'on
me dit depuis maintenant trois ans
quatre ans patrick dit innocent
processus mais coupable donc l'adn c'est
une excellente idée si c'est encore
possible il faut simplement prié ne se
font qu'en techniquement possible qu'on
vienne pas dire que c'est une erreur
judiciaire actionné on n'a pas de parti
pris pour ce gala s'inscrit à un autre
qu'il aurait fait pareil mais tout de
même on peut pas dire que c'est pas lui
quand celles vues avec leurs convictions
respectives
les familles sont parties chacune de
leur côté la justice décidera le 28 juin
en du sort de patrick dils
c'est des gens soit presque une première
en onze ans la cour de révision d'un
statut et qu'une seule fois en matière
criminelle dans la bataille de paris
claquements de portes ou rpr qui
risquent de secouer une nouvelle fois
les instances du parti gaulliste edouard
balladur retire sa candidature à
l'investiture
évoquant le manque de transparence de la
procédure de désignation autrement dit
les dés seraient piper un coup de
théâtre qui suscite ce soir de
nombreuses réactions car le comment
un simple communiqué edouard balladur
s'est refusé aujourd'hui a commenté son
retrait de la course à la mairie de
paris laissant à son entourage le soin
de dénoncer une procédure qualifiée de
simulacre la réunion hier soir de la
commission d'investiture du rpr aurait
été la goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder
le vase
aucune décision alors que philippe
séguin semble déjà avoir été choisi
philippe séguin qui se garde bien
d'entrer dans la polémique
s'agissant de monsieur balladur
je souhaite qu'il prenne vers demain
toute sa part au combat difficile
et tour ce qui vous concerne si je
devais adopter mais c'est ce que je lui
demande horaires sortie du jeu voilà
donc edouard balladur très demandé
françoise de panafieu s'est empressé
aujourd'hui de reprendre le flambeau
lâché par l'ancien premier ministre
aujourd'hui on nous a dit bien souvent
que nous mettions pas fondamentalement
différent dans notre projet l'un et
l'autre
je continuerai à défendre nos idées le
retrait d'edouard balladur une bonne
surprise aussi pour jean tiberi qui
avait déjà claqué la porte de la
commission d'investiture la semaine
dernière tout ça a été réglé d'avancé ça
fait pas très sérieux
c'est une pantalonnade voilà un nouveau
coup dur en revanche pour michèle alliot
marie
le retrait d'edouard balladur ne fait
qu'ajouter un épisode à l'interminable
feuilleton de la mairie de paris la
présidente du rpr se retrouve au pied du
mur il faut sortir de la crise et
surtout éviter le ridicule et du côté de
la majorité critique et ironie avec ses
déclarations d'abord celle du candidat
socialiste à la mairie de paris bertrand
delanoë qui parle de feuilleton
grotesque et confirme l'impasse profonde
et du rpr et puis pour le chef de file
des verts au municipal
la procédure du rpr est une grande farce
et là on touche le fond
l'actualité sociale avec l'entrée en jeu
d'un conciliateur dans le confit des
convoyeurs de fonds peut être un homme
providentiel christian proville
pour cette journée de négociations a
rencontré tour à tour et chacun leur
tour syndicats et patrons pas d'avancées
substantielles mais la porte n'est pas
fermée
gilles marinais beurre numério frédéric
faure pas de déclaration
pas très bavard le conciliateur sa
mission il est vrai consiste en premier
lieu à écouter les grévistes comme les
patrons reçue une à une les délégations
syndicales ont maintenu leurs
revendications notamment celle d'une
prime mensuelle de 1500 francs nets
laissant entendre que la négociation
pouvait reprendre mais qu'elle ne serait
pas bâcler nous avons demandé que quelle
que soit l'heure le jour où on finisse
les négociations on nous laisse
la l'espace de liberté de temps pour
pouvoir consulter les salariés pour que
ce soit eux qui disent et ce qu'ils
pensent du protocole d'accord au dixième
jour de grève chacun souhaite trouver
une issue mais pas à n'importe quel prix
la marge de manoeuvre du conciliateur
est faible l'ultime proposition
patronale porterait la prime mensuelle
amis francs nets à condition que l'état
mette la main à la poche exonérations de
charges sociales
à ce moment là la prime qui était de 12
mille francs brut viendrait
d'intervention de l'état et souhaité par
plusieurs centrales syndicales et la
négociation pourrait reprendre ce
week-end invité à participer les
donneurs d'ordres banques et grandes
surfaces n'ont pas donné suite
estimant que le conflit social n'est pas
de leur ressort demain après-midi
l'aiderait vie seront une nouvelle fois
dans la rue
manifestation des infirmiers
anesthésistes dans plusieurs villes de
france et notamment à paris où plusieurs
centaines d'entre eux ont défilé près du
ministère de la solidarité avant de
tenter d'envahir le siège du parti
socialiste quelques heurts avec les
forces de l'ordre deux manifestants ont
été blessés et puis en fin d'après midi
le ministère de la solidarité accepté le
principe d'une grille de rémunération
spécifique une affaire donc à suivre une
journée de grève dans l'éducation
nationale mais cette fois ci ce sont les
personnels non enseignants dans les
collèges les lycées les sans grades les
employés de service les secrétaires
administratives
jusqu aux assistantes sociales ils se
disent les grands oubliés de la manne
budgétaire
l'exemple en seine-et-marne de ce chef
cuisinier d'une de ses collègues dans
l'un des lycées les moins bien le type
de l'académie de créteil
nabila taboury jean-pierre pasteur avec
600 repas quotidiens sur le fu lee boyer
chef cuisinier dans ce lycée de
seine-et-marne n'a pas une minute à
perdre
ce poste de responsable il occupe depuis
32 ans
le champignon moment donné des
instructions surveiller la cuisson
contrôler les produits et accessoirement
réceptionner les marchandises
il doit veiller au grain mais avec les
années le métier a changé et surtout les
conditions de travail se sont
détériorées pour lui et son personnel
travailler dur c'est vrai que le
personnel soit en le mimant des
polyvalents maintenant c'est vrai que
il est un peu à toutes les sauces c'est
un peu dommage surtout dans la section
cuisine je parle c'est un peu dommage
parce qu'on a du mal à donner des
spécialités aux gens malgré ses
responsabilités guy ne gagnent que 9500
francs de lait par mois pour les autres
les salaires ne dépassent pas les 6500
francs nets de quoi décourager les plus
motivés d'ailleurs guy manque de
personnel certains ont démissionné
d'autres sont en arrêt maladie
mais aucun mais remplacer ceux qui
restent ont un peu l'impression d'être
les laissés-pour-compte de l'éducation
nationale
les mâles reconnu très très mal reconnus
on pense on parle pas souvent de nos
gamins nous l'ailé
les à côtés quoi pour faire face à la
pénurie de personnel trente mille
créations de postes seraient nécessaires
une situation d'une telle urgence que
guy lemire est d'ordinaire non grévistes
ont décidé aujourd'hui de ne pas enfiler
leur tablier un service minimum pour
assurer les liaisons entre la corse et
le continent les grévistes cgt de la
sncm et de l'autre compagnie de
navigation la cmn ont voté à la
quasi-unanimité la reconduction de leur
mouvement avec l'instauration de ce
service minimum la suite du scandale
d'eurotunnel avec l'humour grinçant des
petits actionnaires qui ont décidé
d'organiser soir un dîner de cons en
référence au film
présidée par celui d'entre eux qui aura
été le plus gros jets auparavant une
réunion d'informations réunies c'est cet
après midi la direction et le conseil
d'administration d'eurotunnel david
boeri jean-françois hoffman ruiner
fabienne avait tout misé sur eurotunnel
elle croyait aux grands projets du
siècle aujourd'hui elle a tout perdu ou
presque
aujourd'hui on a une moins value de 400
mille francs
et vous aviez investi combien
sur de l'argent que mon mari avait
économisé pendant des années en se
privant de vacances pour pouvoir rentrer
une entreprise à l'époque elle avait
acheté 90 francs des actions qui valent
aujourd'hui 12 fois - la bourse de paris
comme elle ils sont plus de 600 mille
petits porteurs à se sentir grugés mais
la plupart sont résignés très peu se
sont même déplacés
cet après midi le petit porteur ces six
cent mille personnes mais ils votent pas
c'est trop compliqué d'aller voter
celui qui récupère des pouvoirs en blanc
il suffit d'avoir trois pouvoirs en
blanc de quelques 10000 dix ou vingt
millions de voix et vous gagnez vous
avez un noyau dur qui vous vers nouveau
tunnel comme beaucoup après trois heures
de réunion fabienne ressort de la salle
presque convaincu par les bonnes paroles
de la direction le président console a
promis des annonces de solutions rapides
qui feraient sens et le court une
direction qui semble en tout cas très
sûre d'elle malgré six mises en examen
pour diffusion de fausse information
présentation de faux bilans et abus de
biens sociaux le président se permet
même une pointe d'ironie
la bourse est un jeu difficile dans
laquelle on puisse couper et
deuxièmement quand on se propre n'est
pas nécessairement qu'on
arrivé de faire moi aussi mauvais
investissement à commencer par celui que
j'ai fait en europe humaine parce qu'en
tant qu'actionnaire moi aussi je partage
la déception générale actionnaires
malheureux mais salariés combler en 96
sa rémunération augmente est de 248 m
intrigue console n'a donc pas participé
au dîner de cons organisée ce soir à
paris pour couronner avec humour cet
actionnaire c'est elle qui a le plus
perdu
elle avait acheté ses actions à 123
francs 40 elles valent aujourd'hui 740
l'immense chantier qui doit permettre la
réouverture du tunnel du mont blanc avec
de nouvelles normes de sécurité des
travaux de rénovation qui s'appuie sur
différents rapports d'experts tout
mettre en oeuvre désormais pour empêcher
que ne se reproduise l'effroyable
incendie de mars 99 dans lesquels je
vous le rappelle 39 personnes ont trouvé
la mort
reportage benoît gadret philippe québec
le jour de la catastrophe
les victimes n'ont pu s'échapper et pour
cause la seule issue de secours était le
tunnel lui-même un tunnel très vite
envahi par une fumée épaisse qui a
bloqué l'arrivée des pompiers pour
évacuer les usagers la solution idéale
le percement d'une galerie de secours
parallèle au tunnel est doté de sas qui
permettent aux pompiers de progresser
sans risque avec un véhicule
cette solution a été envisagée quelques
semaines après la catastrophe
vous êtes prêt à percer un tunnel de
secours une galerie de service dans le
tunnel du mont blanc
nous sommes prêts nous avons évalué le
coût prévisible et s'agit d'un cookie 22
les possibilités des deux sociétés et
pourtant ce projet de galerie a été
abandonnée en cas d'incendié les usagers
devront finalement gagné les refuges
puis emprunter un passage pour s'enfuir
par une gaine de ventilation qui se
trouve sous la chaussée cette gaine
transformer en issues de secours at elle
adaptée ce n'est pas l'avis de ce député
auteur d'un rapport sur la sécurité des
tunnels
il s'agit d'une petite galerie de
ventilation dans laquelle je suis
descendu qui est extrêmement étroite et
qui est basse il faut pouvoir permettre
à des véhicules motorisés d'accéder dans
cette galerie car qu'est ce qui a fait
défaut au moment des secours
dans le mont blanc c'est que les hommes
chargés du secours ne parvenait pas à
accéder aux lieux de l'accident
le dispositif est un dispositif qui a
été demandé par les autorités des deux
états qui a été approuvé par la
commission intergouvernementale de
contrôle et surtout par son comité de
sécurité
après une analyse extrêmement détaillé
en clair ce sont les gouvernements
français et italien qui aurait fait ce
choix un choix moins ambitieux mais qui
offre l'avantagé d'être moins coûteux et
de ne pas retarder la réouverture du
tunnel et par souci de sécurité cet
exercice hier dans le tunnel de
puymorens un plan rouge déclenché pour
tester la capacité de réaction des
installations et de la sécurité civile
une simulation d'accident d'une grande
ampleur dans cet axe routier qui relie
donc l'ariège ou pyrénées-orientales
quand on reparle des ogm avec dans
quatre pays européens des graines de
colza génétiquement modifiés planté par
erreur mais apparemment sans danger
c'est du moins ce qu'indique aujourd'hui
les gouvernements concernés c'est à dire
la grande bretagne la suède de
l'allemagne et la france les autorités
françaises qui affirment que ces graines
semées sur 600 hectares ne présente
aucun risque de pollution
you can dommages pour la santé venons en
maintenant à ce rapport alarmant sur la
qualité de l'eau imbuvable presque si
rien n'est fait selon les experts du
fonds mondial pour la nature
l'accumulation de nitrates et de
pesticides dans 11 départements et 30
communes et dangereuse le constat avec
hélène verne et jean-françois hoffman
on savait les rivières et nappes
souterraines souillée par les nitrates
et les pesticides responsable de la
prolifération d'algues vertes cette fois
l'eau que nous buvons est directement
menacée dont deux tiers des départements
étudié les concentrations des eaux en
nitrates dépasse la norme
si l'on continue à partir de 2000 2005
70 % des eaux bretonnes seront impropre
à la production d'eau potable
alors je crois que ça situe bien le
problème
la bretagne partout dénoncé pour son
agriculture intensive montré du doigt
alors qu'elle reçoit toujours autant de
subventions
al'inverse des autres pollueurs les
agriculteurs ne paie aucune redevance
aux agences de l'eau ils sont pourtant
responsables d'environ un tiers de la
pollution rejetée dans les sols
il y a évidemment les agriculteurs qui
tant du point de vue des nitrates que du
point de vue des pesticides ont du mal à
s'engager sur des techniques plus propre
en matière de productions animales ou
végétales
pourtant pour aider les agriculteurs à
limiter leurs pollutions 15 milliards de
fonds étaient dépensés depuis 1994 sans
aucun résultat concret du coup pour
offrir une eau de consommation potable
les distributeurs multiplient les
traitements toujours plus sophistiqués
toujours plus coûteux et l'on ne sait
toujours pas si la présence de nitrates
et de pesticides dans l'eau a des
répercussions directes sur notre santé
la famille de brice fleutiaux reçu par
jacques chirac en fin d'après-midi à
l'elysée détenus en otage en tchétchénie
depuis le 1er octobre dernier
l'extrême inquiétude des proches du
photographe qui depuis son enlèvement a
fait parvenir 5 messages dont un dernier
coup de téléphone 9 avril aujourd'hui la
mère et le frère de brice futures sont
sortis très du sud de leurs entretiens
avec le président de la république
ils ont appris que l'ambassade de france
en russie avait reçu une photographie
une photographie du photographe prise
début mai que cette photographie est
actuellement en voie d'acheminement vers
la france aux philippines deux attentats
dans le sud du pays d'abord dans l'île
de jolo les rebelles détiennent 21
otages quatre personnes sont mortes et
39 autres blessées dans l'explosion de
deux grenades sur un marché public
par ailleurs à zamboanga dans cette
ville à majorité chrétienne toujours
dans le sud
l'explosion d'une bombe dans un
restaurant face à un commissariat a
provoqué la mort d'une personne et
blessé une trentaine d'autres au vatican
l'anniversaire du pape jean paul ii qui
fête ses 80 ans entourée de
cinq mille prêtres évêques et cardinaux
du monde entier le saint père célébré
une messe évoquant sa profession de foi
et sa gratitude au seigneur qui lui
permet de célébrer la joie de la
jeunesse de l'esprit lors de son 80e
anniversaire
une coupe de champagne à la main avec
les astique ont partagé un immense
gâteau avant d'assister comme vous voyez
un concert donné par l'orchestré
philharmonique de londres du sport du
football hier soir au parken stadium de
copenhague l'équipe turque de
galatasaray a remporté la coupe de
l'uefa face aux anglais d'arsenal par 4
tirs au but à 1
cette nuit de violents affrontements ont
opposé des centaines de hooligans
anglais turcs eux notamment qui en fait
une vingtaine de blessés commentaires
carole coelho à chacun ses champs
elysées cet après-midi les footballeurs
du galatasaray ont plus droit à leur
triomphe sur la place taksim la grande
place d'istanbul
plusieurs milliers de supporters pour
les accueillir et fêter la première
coupe d'europe remportée par un club tur
au terme d'un match éprouvant pour les
nerfs
0 0 à la fin du temps réglementaire 0 0
après les prolongations
galatasaray est venu à bout d'arsenal à
l'issue de la séance des tirs au but
et si vieira a tiré sur la barre caisses
couleur ou menthe d'istanbul a donné la
victoire à son club
un pur qui la fête a duré toute la nuit
pour marquer leur joie certains n'ont
pas hésité à tirer des coups de fusil en
l'air
bilan une personne a été tuée et dix
huit ont été blessées cet après midi à
l'aéroport de copenhague de nouvelles
bagarres ont éclaté entre des supporters
anglais et tueur mais cette fois sans
gravité et tout de suite nous retrouvons
en direct de cannes pour une page
spéciale claude sérillon tout près du
palais du festival et sous le soleil
ah oui sous le soleil béatrice mais
alors comme il ya un petit peu de bruit
qu'il y ait un mélange de smoking et
puis de t-shirts de roller et de
limousines que c'est la grande ambiance
dans les rues de cannes quand on est
descendu ici on a laissé les belles
marches vous avez permis de fouler
gilles jacob pour évoquer ce festival de
cannes 53e édition ambitionne ya les
paillettes qui a les films en
compétition les longs et les courts
métrages et puis il ya quelques stars
dont catherine deneuve que nous
retrouverons sur la terrasse du majestic
dans quelques minutes mais auparavant
nous sommes descendus dans les sous-sols
du palais et là c'est la partie qu'on ne
voit pas de l'iceberg 1 milliard de
dollars de chiffre d'affaires sont
échangées dans les sous sols de ce
palais car il se vend des films pour le
monde entier avec une progression de 25%
par rapport à l'année dernière et une
forte présence des asiatiques
et c'est là que jean jacques dufour et
patrick descheemaecker sont descendus
un milliard de dollars au soleil voilà
ce que pèse le marché du film
parce qu'au-delà des paillettes le
festival c'est aussi un immense business
qui oscille entre le monde de l'art et
celui des dollars
ce qui permet au festival de cannes
d'attirer toujours autant de monde c'est
le marché est évidemment ce qui fait le
succès du marché du film c'est la
présence du festival en même temps moins
médiatisé que la montée des marches la
descente
et pourtant le coeur de l'événement
économique il est là dans cette ruche
bourdonnante ou 6000 participants
distributeurs producteurs exportateurs
réalise un volume d'affaires qui dépasse
le milliard de dollars beaucoup d'argent
beaucoup de films oui donc on a
pratiquement 600 films qui seront
projetés pendant le marché 4 bobines en
moyenne de 1400 bobines de films qu'il
faut gérer
nuitée jour envoyés dans toutes les
salles on a une trentaine de salles de
projection et on organise un peu plus de
1200 projection des projections ou les
distributeurs travaillent comme des
orpailleurs
il faut trouver le filon les films qui
feront un gardon en moyenne dans un
festival en tant qu'acheteur vont vous
voyez combien de films parmi les films
qui pourraient l'intéresser il ya celui
qui exportent jacques le blue harry un
ami qui vous veut du bien
projeté en compétition officielle le
film a fait un tabac
résultat mercure distribution a déjà
engrangé 10 millions de francs cannes
c'est quand même le moment le plus fort
de l'année c'est là où les sociétés
comptent environ 50% leur chiffre
d'affaires donc cannes c'est l'enjeu
majeur de tous les producteurs et
exportateurs des français qui sont
obligés d'être bilingue parce qu'ici
tout est en anglais
même le journal du marché pour qu en
anglais parce que ici 85% des ddd des
professionnels sont étrangers et que
même les français par l'anglais donc
cesser la langue bus c'est la langue du
cinéma du business du cinéma et vous
titille triés sur quoi hier sur
l'activité des dotcoms compagnie les
sociétés d'internet qui est un d un des
faits marquants cette année du festival
c'est la révolution internet parce que
ça tout le monde se met dessus sont
servis à exactement ce que c'est
quel est le côté juridique est pas au
point le côté technique et pas au coin
mais tout en dormant
autrement dit au palais s'il ya une
révolution c'est bien celle-là
la souris est entré et doucement elle
commence à grignoter
bonsoir catherine deneuve
c'est gibier regarder le nombre de fois
vous êtes venu à cannes je sais pas
combien vous êtes très fidèle au
festival de cannes
non moi je considère pas ça comme une
fois je vois pas ça comme une fidélité
non j'aime bien
quand les films sont en compétition mais
je dois avouer que des fois je viens
parce que les films sont en compétition
ce n'est pas vraiment quelque chose qui
me remplit de joie c'est même assez a
dit savoir ce qui est paradoxal c'est
que au fond il n'y a jamais eu de vraie
reconnaissance pour l'actrice catherine
deneuve
car oui bah ça me gêne pas trop parce
que voyez la preuve je suis quand même
toujours là et je viens pour les filmer
comme il faut dire que je suis pas très
compétition 1 par moussa donc c'est vrai
que c'est pas c'est pas vraiment un
problème
à l'aller à la fois j'ai pas de troupes
pas envie d'y aller quand même au départ
et en même temps ne tient pas de
récompense je suis pas quelqu'un de très
de très malheureux et ce qui me permet
sans doute aussi de continuer comme ça
je suis pas créé les récompenses me
semble vraiment un plus
et c'est très très bien quand on les a
mais quand on les a pas franchement je
suis pas traitées alors on va parler
d'un moment d'émotion hier on va voir
quelques instants de ce qui s'est passé
après le film de lars von trier il ya eu
un vrai choc je crois parmi ceux qui ont
eu à se voir la projection hier on vous
voit vous même materner quasiment viaur
m
à
mais
vous l'avez quasiment materner 7
islandaise bjork que vous hier peut-être
oui c'est moi je trouve c'est embêtant
ce que six as et robuste embêtant
simplement je suis avec elle et je sais
qu'elle est très timide et très très
sensible et qu' elle n'est pas venue à
la conférence de presse est quelqu'un
qui peut pas affronter comme ça les
groupes importants
elle est quand même venu mais elle avait
du mal à tout assumer elle m'avait
demandé dans l'après-midi
comment ça se passe et comment là je lui
avais essayé d'expliquer que j'avais de
toute façon que je la prendrai par la
main que je l'espérais parce que le
problème ce qu'on entend pas beaucoup et
que à la fois ça va très vite en même
temps ça me semble très très long donc
je lui a expliqué plus tôt à droite et à
gauche et d'avancer et tout ça mais bon
elle est adorable on dirait un petit
elfe elle est vraiment est vraiment
étonnante alors dans le film de
l'argenterie faut jouer une ouvrière
c'est là encore vous nous surprenait et
je sais j'avais lu quelque chose il ya
un an le 10e et je vais jouer quelque
chose qui est aux antipodes de mon monde
à moi de mon âge du monde de cinéma si
vous voulez dû grandir et dedans mais je
voudrais bien que mes amis qui ont pas
été étonnés en voyant le film parce que
moi je suis une femme
je suis une actrice est vrai jeu mais je
suis dans la vie quelqu'un de très de
très concret je suis surtout une femme
très manuelle donc là le père délaissant
après oui mais ça s'était plutôt je
dirais une
c'était un challenge au départ et un
petit peu plus vite qu'on ne le croit
mais après j'ai été quand même une
grande grande liberté une grande ou une
grande liberté et travaille dans une
usine et faire des dévié en métal et
travailler sur des machines comme ça et
c'est pas quelques ce qui
m'impressionnait l'équipe des peurs et
c'était quelque chose avec lequel je me
sentais assez à l'aise maintenant savoir
si les gens pour m'accepter je veux dire
donner un rôle comme ça c'est différent
parce que je pense que les gens souvent
vous aime comme ils vous connaissent ils
n'aiment pas trop qu'on change troll
quand même les donc on verra mais iriez
vous qu'il est nécessaire de se laisser
prendre par le rôle de ce décès accaparé
par le personnage que oui parce que même
quand on croit qu'en se laisse et qu'on
se donne aux metteurs en scène ou filmer
au on a souvent inconsciemment et en a
on a beaucoup quand même deux de réserve
gipat réticences dans tous les cas de
réserve donc même quand on croit qu'on
est entièrement pour on a souvent quand
même des difficultés donc c'est très
important d'essayer de travailler avec
des metteurs en scène ici on a vraiment
une grande confiance parce que c'est
s'il ne va pas au bout des choses et
c'est vrai qu'on sait déjà qu'on
n'arrive pas toujours à accomplir allait
complètement aussi loin qu'on le
voudrait donc il faut donner le maximum
de chances au départ
comment nourrissez vous votre votre
travail vous nous et c'est par la
lecture par l'activité part d une
conversation approfondie par comment ça
ça je crois à la lecture non parce que
je suis une femme
trop en mouvement malheureusement mais
je crois par mon attachement aux choses
de la vie à l'actualité oui sûrement aux
gens aux gens qui me sont proches vos
amis aux relations que j'ai à la je
crois à la curiosité que j'ai pour la
vie tout court et pour la vie pour la
vie des autres partout je crois que
c'est vraiment une je peux pas dire si
j'ai toujours été comme ça c'est une
telle osmose pour moi si vous voulez à
la fois le cinéma et les aces qui ne me
nourris dans les films que je sais plus
quelle est vraiment la part j'aurais pu
faire vraiment la part des choses mais
c'est évident en tous les cas que ce
n'est pas la lecture c'est pas sympa
décision mûrement réfléchie
c'est beaucoup l'instinct l'intuition
mes erreurs et puis j'ai eu la chance de
m'engager aussi avec des gens que
j'estime que j'admire beaucoup donc de
ne pas regretter mes erreurs aussi
et par exemple vous pourriez jouer dans
un film de ken loach un film très
politique très engagé ah oui ah oui
j'admire beaucoup ken loach et
et ça ne me gênerait pas du tout non pas
du tout mais vous avez se trouve que le
dancer in the dark est un film très
politique je raffole par l'évasion en
même temps oui mais c'est quand même
infime mais je pense qu'en amérique
d'ailleurs ce sera peut-être un peu
difficile c'est quand même un des plus
gros plaidoyer que j'ai vu contre la
peine de mort donc je trouve que c'est
un film qui a quand même aussi cette
dimension là alors l'actualité de calmes
aujourd'hui c'est le film aux détails
sur qui pour pascal deschamps va nous
présenter ce film qui est en compétition
avec qui pour amos gitaï raconte une
guerre qui a fait irruption dans sa vie
tranquille d'étudiants un jour d'octobre
73 dès son arrivée sur le fond il est
intégré à une unité secouriste ce jeune
homme brun frisé pencher sur un cadavre
c'est lui il avait 23 ans 27 ans au
passé lorsqu'il se résout à tourner
cette histoire pour donner sa vision de
la guerre au moyen-orient
la guerre de kippour une guerre
particulière c'est un p comble que le
premier tir mondiale en europe
c'est à dire c'est des armes est très
fort qui vit en collision direct et à la
fin du sort de cette guerre étudié six
tours et ses 22 mais pourquoi et je
crois que les gens de ma génération y
c'est une impression pourquoi
s'il y a quelqu'un dans cette région
qu'il a un très fort désir de répéter
des rituels des guerriers c'est bien
qu'ils regardent les images
avec mon ami et le soulman palestiniens
avec omar amiralay syrien je trouve que
le cinéma il est il le langage de
dialogue c'est pas un langage très forte
de la politique direct au lac militaires
y sont plus efficaces entre guillemets
de transformer la réalité mais les
cinémas et doit rester toujours une
façon de dialoguer des de traverser les
line quelquefois des stupidités pour
amos gitaï connaît donc l'indispensable
vitrine de cette communauté des
cinéastes
par delà les frontières la politique
nous intéresse parce que la politique
c'est la vie donc elles m'intéressent
jusqu'à un certain point je ne fais pas
de jeu n'est pas d'engagement si vous
les politiques mais pour moi c'est
aujourd'hui un oui c'est vraiment
indissociable de la vie de l'intérêt
pour la vie les autres et ma vie aussi
oui en fait vous êtes une femme qui
cultivait les surprises je trouve pas ce
que vous passez de carax à garcia de
téchiné à lars von triers où vous êtes
là où on vous attend pas
c'est c'est une volonté vous avez envie
que chaque fois ce soit une expérience
non parce que je crois que c'était une
volonté y aurait quelque chose de
mécanique et des choix ce qui serait
plus des surprises parce qu'on ne
saurait si c'est une surprise ça veut
dire que vraiment c'est toujours non
franchement là je suis assez en accord
avec moi-même c'est vraiment des choix
sont des choix de dents vie de rencontre
beaucoup de hasards aussi un heureux
hasard de gens et de d'intuition comme
ça de travail et que certaines personnes
ce qui me dirige le plus c'est la
curiosité c'est vrai que c'est un
intérêt de participer à un projet plus
véritablement qu'un rôle d'ailleurs dans
le film de lars von trier ce n'est pas
le rôle principal et ça a été lourd par
moments de ce fait dès le tournage était
très long le danemark
si vous voyagez souvent des
allers-retours et ma présence dans le
film est important mais ce n'est pas une
présence est pas la première présence
céline fille parce que viscéralement
vous êtes une femme attachée votre
indépendance c'est pour ça que vous
voulez pas vous laisser enfermer dans un
rôle ou dans un autre non je pense pas
parce que moi je m'enferme pas dans
l'est dans les films moi j'ai une autre
une autre
un autre fonctionnement mais décalage
ils sont ailleurs et moi je rentre je
n'en ai jamais complètement dans l'ain
film j'ai besoin oui oui non gérante
tellement dedans dans la journée que
j'ai absolument besoin d'en sortir le
soir
sinon je pense pas que je pourrai
continuer je ne pourrais pas continuer
encore à faire des films
non non c'est trop c'est trop prenant et
j'ai besoin de retrouver vraiment mon
univers mes amis même même si c'est pas
raisonnable j'ai sur le soir je dîne
dehors ah oui oui alors on va on va
écouter sans doute avec émotion marcello
mastroianni c'était en 1996 c'était ici
d'ailleurs avec votre fille et il évoque
le privilège d'être acteur bien d'accord
avec lui je n'aime pas les légendes
qu'on fait si les acteurs quand ils
disent qu'il souffle
mais quand il est à souffrir à 8 l
ouverture vient vous prendre avec l'air
conditionné l'été où jamais un studio
tout le monde vous dit bonjour vous avez
bien dormi kaka tout à d'autres et
d'autres règles eh bien vous voulez un
café aller au maquillage ils sont pas
prêt encore tout dans mon tour de vous
bougez où ça va votre fille elle va bien
elle fait du cinéma oui le bien oui et
vous maquille je m'endors généralement
parce que le matin on est encore un
petit peu comme ça puis toutes les
lumières autour du miroir
les types qui vous fait un massage du
cercle mais j'adore ma maman la bise
mais tient la tête car dix projets me
rééduquer qui est ce jour ce jeune
premier il m'a tout arranger la vie vous
descendez aussi de mes tracés le coma
qui a bien dormi et bien tu veux qu'on
va confirmer c'est la somme
le soir ils vous ramène à la maison vous
avez gagné
radiant quelle foi pour tomber même un
mot tombé amoureux de l'actrice et sont
toujours des belles filles
quel métier de merde mais pourquoi les
américains disent qu'ils soufflent au
tlm à la démystification danfoss
permettent d'être lui est d'avoir le
charme et la chaleur dans la voix pour
dire ça ça pourrait paraître très très
faussement prétentieux c'est vraiment
parce que c'est lui mais je suis bien
d'accord avec lui sur bien des points
c'est vraiment alors quelqu'un qui m'a
beaucoup apporté sur ce plan là je dois
dire c'est vraiment de remettre bien les
choses à leur place aux éleveurs cette
distance c'est difficile de vieillir au
cinéma oui déjà dans la vie n'est pas
facile maintenant le cinéma et je dirais
surtout pour les actrices puisque pour
les acteurs la vie c'est comme dans la
vie très injuste on trouve qu'un homme
de 50 ans a beaucoup de charme et on
trouve qu'une femme de 50 ans est encore
bel bongo de chose que j'attends sont
encore belle oui c'est sûr toujours même
espèce de petit mode réseau non je n'ai
pas de réserves mais c'est une petite
nuance km qui atténue un peu vous aviez
travaillé avec ruiz partir du texte
prouve sur le temps retrouvé et cette
idée du tantad dire de de la
multiplicité des personnages que vous
avez été par rapport à ce que vous êtes
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose
le heat au fond je me suis enrichi tous
ces personnages que j'ai interprétés oui
je pense qu'ils m'ont nourri bon
heureusement je crois que si je
m'arrêtais trop longtemps et que j'y
pensais régulièrement je pense que c'est
une chose qui me rendrait assez
mélancolique d'ailleurs le tournage de
crous a été très agréable mais c'était
assez mélancolique
parce que c'est une vraie réflexion
quand même sur le sur le temps sur la
mort sur les souvenirs ce que vous
n'auriez vous cultivez pas la maison je
ne cultive pas parce que je m'en vais
ici parce que je l'aimé ce serait leur
serait quand même d'une nature assez
mélancolique donc ma façon de lutter moi
c'est beaucoup cette grande ans dans le
l'activité aussi bien professionnels que
dans la vie tous les jours je suis
quelqu'un de très heureusement ma
curiosité me sauve de la mélancolie le
globalement s'il ya quand même plein de
bonheur à exercer ce métier
ah oui comme marché cela dit c'est vrai
que
on veut pas ça veut pas se plaindre ça
métier merveilleux on ne travaille
jamais au même endroit si quelqu'un vous
déçoit vous savez vous avez passé votre
vie avec lui vous travaillez avec
d'autres personnes
ils avaient des rencontres formidables
il faut pas si sa tâche et en croyant
que c'est la vie ces personnes vont
faire partie de votre vie pour toute la
vie être mais bon quand on a tourné
quand même qu'on a de l'expérience qu'on
a fait plusieurs films et jeux ça on
peut vraiment en voir les avantages qui
pue le temps passe et plus
malheureusement les chagrins de la vie
aussi ont pris sur vous malgré tout et
puis on se rend compte à quel point on
est privilégié d'un dans des métiers
aussi aussi difficile mais aussi beau et
aussi gai aussi vivants oui c'est
formidable bon on retiendra cette leçon
je vous remercie nous avoir accordé cet
entretien
bon mais c'est pas une leçon
merci beaucoup de nous avoir accordé cet
entretien on est comme on est bien le
festival de cannes on a voulu terminer
cette séquence du journal avec jean
jacques dufour est quelqu'un qui incarne
peut-être la relève du cinéma quelqu'un
qui s'est beaucoup battu pour faire des
courts métrages c'est une jeune femme
que j'aurais dufour a suivi cet
après-midi sur la croisette et même s'il
n'ya plus de starlettes le cinoche fait
encore tourner les têtes merci monsieur
jolie casquette à propos d' artiste
parlons plutôt de souad el bouhati une
jeune femme de 39 ans qui vient de
réaliser son premier court métrage un
coup d'essai mais aussi un coup de
maître
et je suis très touché que le jury de
clairement et ainsi que tous les
anonymes et est apprécié ce film est
alors la can on fait quoi
je me balade je vais essayer de voir
deux films et j'attends la projo qui a
lieu tout à l'heure
non dénué d'humour cette toulousaine
relativise son succès ça doit être
l'effet zidane dit elle pour rire
je dis souvent que c'est l'effet zidane
chez beaucoup de choses mais on a quand
même beaucoup travaillé je suis très
heureuse c'est sûr mais je n'ai pas 20
ans donc j'ai france a quand même avec
un petit peu de recul mais je suis très
heureux d'être ici et à cannes du recul
et l'enfant puisque vous regardez là
vraiment des fois je sais que c'est
quelqu'un je voudrais je voudrais à
l'aide de laon dans l'aisne de l'eure
n'est pas là à l'aide de lances et
moines amour sur la croisette qui perd
la tête soit souris et ferries est pour
elle tout ça c'est une drôle de fête
ce luxe c'est palace et serra pour moi
c'est du cinéma
du grand cinéma c'est à dire c'est roche
c'est pas mal dit quoi c'est moi ça dans
les films général la croisette et
comment
sur la croisette les enfants rient
ballons rouges pas trop de soucis voilà
quelque chose d'assez joly voilà nous
allons maintenant quitter le festival de
cannes 53e édition va s'éloigner des
marches ou comment sa nouvelle nouvelle
projection sous un élu de protection de
voitures voyez béatrice c'est hyper
surveiller ce festival de cannes
enfin nous avons eu plaisir à y être
pendant cette édition de 20h préparer et
coordonnée par pierre géraud et toutes
les équipes de france 2 merci de nous
avoir suivis et puis ils virent triste
comme vous êtes à paris
eh bien je vais vous laisser faire les
journaux qui suivent mais ici je vais un
peu profiter du soleil et du cinéma
à bientôt et bonbons week end avoue
claude moi je serai en effet aux
commandes du journal demain soir c'est
la fin de cette édition je vous rappelle
le principal titre
coup de théâtre au rpr edouard balladur
considérant que les jeux sont déjà faits
se retire de la course à la candidature
évoquant le manque de transparence
je vous remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2 à
2,20 eur